10 o'rourke against garrett colbert
making his 10th start of the season and
he's had a rough season and most of his
problems related to his inability to
really locate his fastball he's given up
14 home runs this year 10 of those on
fastballs ground ball through for a base
hit so judge now 3 for 18 since coming
off the il he has not shown power yet
but getting his stroke down and that's
the most important thing and he has this
game and five more after to do it now
the yanks have a base runner with one
out and here is aaron hicks
line to base it down the right field
line cutting over as hernandez it gets
by him
judges that third
and they're going to wave him home
and the throw is going to go to third in
there is hicks so it's an rbi triple for
aaron hicks it's one nothing yankees
and that one gets past kirk and here
comes hicks he will score its
two-nothing ex the one-two pitch
swinging to miss got him with a high
fastball torres is down on strikes the
damage minimized by tanner roar garrett
cole with the two-run lead gonna take on
the blue jays tonight in buffalo and
we've noted this will be his 12th start
here's a 3-2 struck came out swinging
high fastball the 1-1
as a ground ball toward the middle
fielded by lemayo behind second throws
to first so one two three and at the end
of one ending to play two nothing yet
griez at 263 10 homers and 30 rbi the
1-2
swinging a line drive into right field
down for a base head
randall grichik has hit third hit of the
series
another opposite field knock for grichik
chop the third there's one on the first
it's a double play as they double up
guriel now five four three gp and in the
inning no runs one hit
and no one left end of two and the ninth
hitter will lead it off with the yanks
tanner roark facing kyle higashioka in
the first pitch swinging is a fly ball
the deep center jonathan davis going
back onto the track in front of the wall
he makes the catch for the first out
kyle higashioka hit it about as far as
you can hit it at salem field without
getting it out of the park le mayhew
grounded a second his first time
there's a swing and a fly ball this time
the left center hit well davis going
back reaches up on the track makes a
great catch and then slams into the wall
face first
that thing took off a little bit on
jonathan davis he had to put the
afterburners on and here is the left
hand hitting second baseman joe panic
there'll be an o2 to panic and the
fastball cut animus that was 98 right
down the pipe right down broadway now
cole deals 1-2 to davis and the breaking
ball is grounded to second lemay who
throws to first you end the inning
another easy inning for
garrett so blayber at second with two
out michelle had a 75-foot single up the
third base line in his first trip
and the [ __ ] is lying to right field
there is a base hit
hernandez feels near the line scoring
his globe it's a base hit and an rbi for
urshela and it's three-nothing yanks
due to ball swinging a miss throwark
strikes him out as frazier drops to a
knee biggio buchet and hernandez against
cole here in the fourth
one one pitch is swung on and hit in the
air deep left center field back goes
hicks he's at the wall it's gone
kevin biggio
touches up garrett cole and the blue
jays are on the scoreboard trailing the
yankees three to one
swing and a miss pachette
down on strikes
sharp slider
swing and a miss hernandez down on
strikes so strikeout number four for
garrett and the yankees have two on and
one out and here is aaron judge ready to
deal and the bitch's line toward left
center in the gap it is a base hit
coming home
is higashiyoka the third iii is not in
time
and judge moves to second on the throw
so an rbi for judge two hits for him
tonight it's 4-1 yanks hicks rbi triple
run scored
ground ball pass to diving guerrero and
it trickles into right field that will
score two runs so hicks with three
ribbies on the night and the yankees
lead six to one
ground ball through for a base hit
hicks rounds third he's coming home
and the throw nut in time and the
yankees now lead seven to one blue jays
down seven to one would love to carve
back into it right now
grounded and right to urshella he's
coming home
and kirk is out
and there are two away
now here's the o2
and the pitch is grounded to third a
shell of steps on third and that ends
the end
all of a sudden two out here in the
bottom of the seventh inning with the
blue jays down by six two-two pitch to
gorielle
and that is strike three outside corner
of the knees i gather garrett cole's
knight is through
and the yankees have runners of first
and second with two out for brett
gardner
that one is punched out to the left side
and over the head abigail into left
field or shella will score
it's an rbi single for gardner and it's
8-1 yanks
that one is drilled deep to left field
that ball is off the top of the wall
it went off the top of the wall
i don't know if it's not a home run
it's a double for higashiyoka
gardner has scored frazier has scored
the yankees have a 10 to one lead and
that will bring up gleiber torres
it's sharply a base hit
for glebe torres
that's going to score judge so taurus
has three hits moving to third is
talkman
and the yankees lead 11-1
that one is off of font
a run will score
and it's going to be another base hit
for arcella a four hit knight
and another ribby
and the yankees lead 12-1